[Music]
will is with us in denver i will welcome
to the ramsay show
hi ken hi dave how's it going better
than we deserve what's up
well your phone screener tells me i have
a good question so hope you agree
okay i've been listening to you
sometimes i agree with her
[Laughter]
what's up sometimes you get called
stupid and arrogant
that's happened too wow will bringing it
today this better be a good question
will with that kind of intro
i'm an avid viewer like
i get even the most excited it was one
of my favorite calls of the last year by
the way
yeah that was that's one of the most
popular calls of the last year so good
call out
it's not just popular on your channel
all the other channels are talking about
it too it's lighting up my youtube feed
sorry what was any more time um
so uh i've been losing you about half my
life like i said and i have been very
inspired by what you said about giving
um i've had the opportunity over the
past couple years to you know be able to
give big or what's big to me
um to people on an individual level and
that's been every bit as rewarding as
you said it would be
as far as the baby steps i now have my
emergency fund and recently became a
homeowner i'd like to start using some
of my freed up cash to give kind of on
an organizational level
i've heard you talk about the importance
of feeling your giving and i was
wondering how i can go about feeling my
giving
when giving to a cause or organization
as opposed to you know just an
individual
if you can allocate some time in your
calendar to interact with the people
that organization is serving
even though you're not handing money
directly to those people
but you're interacting with the people
that it is helping
uh for instance like let's just say i'll
just make up one let's say it's a a
community medical clinic
that helps the underserved with medical
issues in a tough neighborhood okay and
you want to give them i'll make up a
number some substantial money call it
ten thousand dollars okay that would be
organizational giving but you don't you
didn't give to the actual people you
gave to the clinic to take care of them
to support them so they can continue to
do the work that they do we'll go down
there and spend a half a day
and see what they do and talk to the
people that they're serving
and you'll get it you'll get you'll get
it just fine and you really should do
that anyway if you can if you're going
to make a substantial gift because
that's just due diligence to make sure
that your giving is going to something
that is actually
pulling off what it is they claim
they're doing
that makes it make sense
absolutely yeah so my daughter my
daughter denise runs our family
foundation and that's actually her job
she spends time with the ministries that
we're going to give to or consider
giving to
to determine that they're really getting
it done that they're really effective we
pretend like we're investing in a
company and we want to make sure that
company is being run well because we're
investing god's money
what are red flags we look for
i'm sorry
what are red flag
what are red flags you look for when you
do this betting i want to know what
percent i look at their budget for one
thing in our case we don't give to
ministries that take on debt because we
don't support a bank
we're there to support the ministry and
we don't believe in debt so be a little
inconsistent if we don't borrow money
but we give to something that does so we
don't i'm not saying you have to do that
but that's a red flag we look for uh
another red flag we look for is the
percentage of the
uh
charity work that's
of the in total you know these these
non-profits are all profitable if a
non-profit that's not profitable goes
out of business
okay it's just an accounting entry that
makes it a non-profit so they have to be
bringing in more than they have going
out or they they go away so how are they
managing that and what percentage of
their top line so to speak their total
revenue incoming is going to
administrative
versus actually feeding the hungry if
they're supposed to be feeding the
hungry or buying or providing medical
care in the example i gave a minute ago
so i'm looking for percentages on that
and and you know believe it or not we've
run into things that 90 cents out of
every dollar is going to administrative
and only 10 cents is going to help the
actual people so all we're doing is
paying for people to have a job we're
not paying we're not giving to the
actual person that's in need through
this organization so we don't give to
that one by the way if it's if it's that
high ken what else do you think it's in
that line i i would follow right off of
dave after you look at the percentage of
the money on administrative costs versus
whatever the actual product is the
service the type of service i'd be uh
hanging out with those people uh to see
how they run their events you know or
whatever that need that they're uh
serving what's it look like and i think
you can do that when you do what dave
recommended first which is you know just
get around the ministry not just to kind
of see what they're doing but watch how
they run things you know one of the
things i've grown up in ministry one of
the things that i think sometimes we as
investors and i love that dave laid it
out this way we kind of overlook people
because it's while they got a good heart
well the reality is is if if they're not
doing as good as they could be doing to
the point where they're only kind of
addressing a surface issue and they're
mismanaging their time volunteers time
and funds i would look at that too not
from a critical spirit but this is
an investment that you're making and i
would look at that too because if it's
poorly managed and poorly run
that's a problem too it is not mean no
there's a lot of need yeah a lot of need
there's more need than you'll ever have
money there's someone out there hurting
more
a bazillion times more than you'll have
personal money
that you can do so what you what you're
looking for
is not the
not not how much the need is real the
need is almost always valid the need is
almost always real the person hurting on
the other end the people needing
assistance on the other end is almost
always very real the question is not the
is the need valid the question is are
you called to the need
number one and then number two are the
people taking care of them competent
and efficient in taking care of the need
um otherwise you're just wasting your
money it's exactly right it's just a
waste and good intentions don't mean
anything if i intend to send my wife
flowers for valentine's day i get zero
points
so you got good intentions or bogus i've
got a good heart i do have a good heart
i love my wife but i forgot to send her
flowers i didn't by the way but thank
god but um but
you know you know that doesn't mean i'm
a bad person if i forgot it just means i
was incompetent that's correct i didn't
do my job
and so you can't finance that kind of
stuff or you shouldn't finance that
stuff based on he's got a good heart the
need is real but they're not competent
that's correct that's not money that's
not a place you put money that's bad use
of god's resources
and so and that's not to say i hate that
person or i don't believe in the need i
like the person but i just don't believe
in them i don't believe they're
competent i don't believe they're doing
a good efficient job of bringing
healing to that area of need or bringing
help to that area
because here's the flip side if you go
and see several organizations and let's
say three out of four it's kind of like
their pants are on fire that's a warning
sign but you find an organization that's
doing really good work and it's
efficient guess what those dollars that
you're investing are going to come back
with a higher return that's why we're
saying this on disaster relief
if you put up the red cross beside
samaritan's purse
blow your mind
how much more efficient samaritan's
purse is
how
light years
they are in terms of carrying baggage
around but both do a good job and both
are serving disasters
but which is doing the most efficient